okay so uh the naga euka dynamic is a
simulated conflict it's a simulated
clash between uh yong and yang okay
and what it's working with is that uh
you're a young value so all clashes are
generated by you
okay if you didn't go young against that
yawn you wouldn't have the clash
so it starts with the yongyang clash
which is demonstrated by
uh he's extending and then i push into
that
uh extension do you see that
and then his job is to now
reconcile the young young clash but
guess what stop yangon
okay
uh but the problem is
that our fear
or our desire
is going to always add to the clash
versus not add to the clash okay
um and we either have we have two
options at which point either you
overpower the clash or you lose the
clash do you see
um
and there's a third option stop clashing
okay
uh that way you don't have to be
stronger than the other person
uh and also you have no possibility of
losing this thing because you stopped
clashing all right so
um
he is going to push do you see how he's
pushing he's pushing whoa
uh and what i'm going to do is just
redirect his push over here
so as opposed to wait wait i'm not ready
that's all young do you see instead of
just pushing i just leave them here
so it's not that i'm leaving him
is that he's pushing or i let him push
that over there okay
so i'm not leaving him or pulling him
all right let's chase
[Music]
okay let's try that true
so you know theory causes that
everything is uh yin and yang so
if he's pushing i'm
yielding here do you see that that was
the end
he goes
but you know what that's not the art i
only have two movements i have a dimmer
spiral and outward spiral so my hand's
not gonna go like this
[Music]
the same thing going like this with my
hand like that that's not a spiral
[Music]
i'm saying my hind bone like this
that's not a spiral that's a flat circle
i also have my rules okay they're too
close to your body
so my elbows have to stay in their yin
yang faces both
on the sagittal plane and the horizontal
plane so it has to look like this
okay let's try it again so
i have in my aikido camouflage
so i'm doing the outward spiral the our
spiral goes like this we see it comes
back out
but i'm turning my hips so you cannot
see that it's doing that so my hip
change rotation okay but so i'm not
painting a circle on the ground
and it goes like that
if i stay still that arm will go like
this
my arm is going back that way but i turn
my hips
so i'll exaggerate the end is where you
can see that
right here going out outward
the
[Music]
but
amber's spider okay and now he's gonna
push back into me there's another clash
right here
oh it pushes drives back into me
homeless
push it
pushes again
[Music]
he's going this way okay
now the key is
you have to
it's relate i'm in the yangyang clash
okay
you have to be
in sync with his actual intentions this
is too late too
but you're not leaving him
you're actually just reading his body
[Music]
so
okay let's try again
i think you could all feel that during
the transitions you were passing through
a young young clash okay
so that means that you deviated from the
model that was being shown so now we
just have to find the deviation so one
of the common ones that i saw is uh you
know you you have an obvious
understanding of kazushi which is i'm
gonna pull their line of gravity outside
their base of support well okay maybe
but you can't do that via yangyang clash
okay
so uh you're over here and you go like
this
and he turns towards you and
well that was a young young clash even
though
it isn't a push push it is a pull pull
do you see and then when you try to
reverse that okay
you see that that should have been
another yield so you're going over this
way
and you are going this way so think more
in lines of energy you're pulling this
okay
when you start to go backwards
or back that way it's into against where
he is going you see that and then well
if you're strong enough you kind of get
some
thing
um if you're not strong enough it pushes
you over okay
um
the other one
uh
that i saw
uh was again
you're
not affecting your center so you came
over here but you're in front of them
okay so let me give you a reference
point and the reference point is the
elbow you see his elbow okay
um so
and as he turns into me
i don't want to extend this arm because
that's going to be my young young clash
even though it's a pull pull variant and
now when you go back
you have to try to get back what you had
before okay
so instead
well how far do i yield
don't open his elbow so his elbow is
sure on the first move and on the second
move his elbow is going to stay in that
same position
okay
so we'll do that again
whoa okay there's his elbow this elbow
keeps that same angle as i do the next
move turn this way
okay as i go this elbow keeps the same
angle
okay you see that
um
so
here is your same control point so if he
wanted to push in he can't he can't push
in because i'm ground victory and of
course
you can push out on that elbow
that's my control point
i just yield it to it and now i use it
this way
long elbow
and notice how i trade places with the
elbow so i'm not in front of it okay so
as we go here this is going this way i
do move off to the side
but as the elbow continues to rotate i
continue to rotate
okay
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
okay let's try this
here come back up right
[Music]
wow
here comes this push don't stand there
that would be my fault i stayed there
adam pressured
and then
here he goes
[Music]
there is a tiny window
where i can get it
basically
but not push me till about there
okay
if i didn't move it all as i
demonstrated last time it'll push you
right away
boom
so i just need a small window in order
to do what's it
okay
and that's the arm pasta as you're
[Music]
of course you can see you're supposed to
knock it in there right
[Music]
he might stop he might change levels so
we're just yielding we'll go slow so
he's like he's pushing
okay i push him into the hour
he's pushing okay
we'll take him around today
you go slow here
push don't be here
start to neutralize that energy
here
it's off into the arm
okay
try it